では よろしくお願いします
と 話は聞こえますかね
えーと 今日あの ちょっと足が苦しいかもしれませんだけど
とにかく前の方にぶつからないように伸ばしてもよろしいんです
ぶつかった人は喜んでいるんだったらぶつけてもいいんですけど
まあそれはちょっと聞いてみないとわからないんです
まあどうせ悪魔の話ですからね
えーと 一応地獄の話ということで
まあちょっと面白く 閻魔何でしたっけ？閻魔大王は本当にいるの？ということで
まあ地獄に対して仏教の考え方はね
まあテーマは一応英語のタイトルで Buddhist Concept of Hell という
まあ地獄に対して仏教の考え方ということでいきます
はい 次に行きます  地獄の話っていうのは
私は覚えてないんですから
見ないと まあ脅しですね
一応 人間というのは地獄があるんだぞと言ったら怖くなっちゃって
まあ言うとおりにするということになるんですよ
そういうわけで脅しにもなります
なんで脅しっていうのは
このもう何でもかんでもあれこれやと言われるとおりにやられることはね
人はもうやりたくない
嫌なものもありますけどね
まあそこは一応脅しということになります
仏教にも地獄の話ありますから
結局 仏教の場合でも脅しでしょうかというと
仏教は別にあれこれやというんじゃなくても
もう悪いことやめなさいよと
悪いことをやめることはどうせ悪いことじゃないし
悪いことっていうのは自分の不幸になること
他人の不幸になること
世界に迷惑になること
そんなのは誰でもやりたくないでしょうに
やりたくないんだけど
やってしまいますね ですから
悪いことをしたら悪い結果があるんだよと
だからちょっと踏ん張ってやめなさいという話ですから
あの まあそんなに脅しということになりません
他宗教の永遠な地獄は極端に脅し
まあ他宗教ではこの永遠の地獄という考え方がありますね
大体人間というのは この永遠という言葉
すごい好きですよ 好きだからこそ
全くもあほったれの考え方なんです
全くも無意味な非論理的な考え方なんですよ
だって永遠という言葉
どうやって成り立つんですかね
どうやって無限に永遠と言えるんでしょうかね
言えないはずでしょうに
客観的に言えば それで人間というのはいつでも永遠永遠永遠と
人間の魂は永遠だと 天国に行けば永遠に楽しみますよと
それで地獄に行っちゃったら永遠に苦しみますよという
もう最初からもう根拠のない非論理的な
いわゆるヘリクツの上に成り立っている概念で
それそんなものを嘘を言って人を脅すということは大変な危険なことなんですね
なぜならば 論理的に言えば 2行目で書いてますけど
おそらく 3行目は真だと思いますよ
あの limited activities do not produce unlimited results という
我々の行為っていうのは有限
我々には無限大に行為できるわけじゃないんですよ
やっていることっていうのはいつでも有限なんですよ
例えば 生まれた瞬間から死ぬ時まで喋りっぱなしでいるそうで
ありえない話でしょうに
喋りっぱなしでいるそうと言ったっても
何時間 何分 何秒喋ったのかっていうことは計算できるでしょうに
もし仮定するなら 生まれた瞬間で人が喋り出したと
それから絶えず止まることなく
死ぬ瞬間まで喋り続けていたんだと
だからってそれは無限の行為じゃないんですよ
何時何分 何秒で始めて
何時何分 何秒で話が終わったのかっていうことは言えるんだから有限なんですよ
だから有限な行為には無限な結果あるっていうのは
ちょっと経済学的にはならない
合わないでしょうに  100円持っていたら
世の中にあるものは何でも買えるそうと
買っても買っても終わらないんだよと
また買えるそうということはならないでしょうに
100円持っていると
100円の値打ちのものしか買えないんです
仏教はそういう立場なんですよ
それから神に逆らう悪魔の誘惑に負けると付与付けがあります
そこでこの神に逆らったんだと
これは永遠の罪であると
悪魔の誘惑に負けたと
これって永遠の罪だと
と言うならば この罪を何といいますか
免除してもらうこともできるんでしょうに
でもそういう宗教で教えてるで
罪をなんて全部償ってあげるそうと
あなたは悔い改めればもう泣くパーになっちゃいますよと
ならないはずなんですけど
それだったら まあ一応まあちょっと理屈はならざるを得ないんですね
そういうことになると
神の行為っていうのは道徳的かないかという問題も
我々仏教徒はちょっとからかって聞くんですよ
まあそんなのは侮辱じゃなくて
他宗教に対してちょっとからかってるだけの話で
あの 神に逆らうことも
悪魔の誘惑に負けることも自己責任だそうです
それで言うんだ それは自分の責任だと
自由意思を与えた神に落ち度がなさそうと
神は自由意志を与えて
それを我々人間が自由意志を使って神に逆らっちゃうんですね
あるいは悪魔の誘惑に負けると
で 罰を与えるのは神ですよ
それでも だったら自由意志を与えた瞬間でそれを記録してほしいんですよ
これ悪いように使ってはいけませんと
なんでそもそもくれたんですかね
そんなのは 不公平な罰を与える神にまた罪がない
だから自分が与えた自由意志を悪く使ったんだからといって罰を与える
もう神に罪罪はないんですね
審判する神のその行為は
憐れみ 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ
どちらですかね 例えば人が死んだら
最後の審判で神様が永遠な地獄だという
汝は私を信仰しなかったと
だから永遠な地獄に落とそうと
この行為が憐れみですかね
嫉妬 憎しみですかね そういうふうに疑問にした方がいいんですよ
聖書というのは 神はものすごい怒りと憎しみ
嫉妬心だと言ってるんだからね
だから嫉妬に の衝動で生きている方っていうのは
真面目に信じるかないかっていうのは
仏教は信じません とにかく神様にも一つ用意してあげなくてはならない
神様にも だから ちょっと一つ地獄を用意した方がいいんじゃないんですか
すごい悪いことしてるんだから
だから 物事を論理的に考えてほしいんですよ
永遠の地獄の観念に脅されて行う善行為は純粋ではありません
そういうわけで 我々は本当は悪いことをしたいんだけど
永遠の地獄なんかには落ちたくないという脅しでやっている良いことっていうのは
そんなに純粋じゃないんですよ
仏教から見れば 汗かいて心清らかにしたいっていう気持ちはないんです
ただ脅されているだけで
そういう方々は もし永遠の地獄がなかったら
やりたい放題やる だからそんなのは善行為にはなりません
善行為ですけど 純粋じゃないんですね
神を恐れているんだから良いことをしているんだと
だから仏教は神を設定しないで善行為
すごいしっかりと成立して語っているんですよ
だから地獄があってもなくても
仏教の世界では良いことをしなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで はい 次に行きます
原始時代からも人間は審判制度を持っていたのいたでしょう
人間というのは原始時代からも
もの人が人を審判する
裁くということがあったんですよ
じゃあ原始時代どういうものかというと
やっぱり原始時代 道具生活をしている時でも
力強い人は力弱いものをいじめたり
もうお前何やってるんでしょうかとかね
殴ったり蹴ったりはしていたんですよ
もうもう家族みたいな制度はあったかどうか分かりません
だけど その時でも男は力強いし
もうそれでもう体力でもって弱いものを抑えるということは当然あったし
それで体力ある人が何が正しい
何が悪い自分勝手に決めるでしょ
だから原始時代でも人間というのはそういうことはあったんでしょうし
しかし 昔だったら気が弱い人
体力が弱い人 言うことは聞かないでしょうね
大体力で暴力で抑えてるんですよ
それ今でもあるんですよ
だって我々は警察は怖いのはどういうわけですかね
向こうは法律と人を取り調べて罰を与える力を持ってるんですね
だから我々はそういう意味で弱いんですね
もし法律 警察がね そういう権利がなかったならば
人間はもう全然聞かない
だから一人の警察がね
100人の人間でも教えることは簡単にできるんですよ
別に体力があるわけじゃないんですよ
力ありますよ それでも
それは合法的なことで
昔だったらやっぱり体力
暴力主義なんですね そういう制度があったんです
はい そのシステムの形而上学的なバージョンではないでしょうかと
この神が審判する全ての生命をということは
この原始時代からの我々経験している
この裁判制度の形而上学的なバージョンなんですね
神だからもう絶対わからない
もう信じるしかない世界だから
形而上学的なんですね
メタフィジックスですね
調べる方法もできない
そういうわけであんまり真剣に考える必要はないんですよ
ただ 人間の歴史から見れば
この神様が永遠な地獄も作って
永遠な天国を作って そこで自分勝手に審判するんだということの暴力主義で
すごい力があって 我々は何の力もなくて
平等っていうのはひとかけらもなくて
で 言われる通りにしなくちゃいけないということになってます
思想 思想を分析してみるとそうなるんですよ
だから私の考え方は これはこの原始時代から人間持っていた人間の社会にあった
この裁判制度 審判制度
人を人を裁くという そういう制度の形而上学的なバージョンですよ
そんなもんで 次に行きます
脅迫的な道徳の欠落 道徳そのものが必要がないかは気にしない
だからこういう永遠の地獄とかね
そういう考え方があると
例えば日本的に言えば
閻魔様に舌が抜かれるそうと言われると
じゃあ嘘をつくことは必要がないかと考えませんよ
ただ 舌が抜かれ 舌を抜かれるのは嫌で
嘘をつくことをやめるんです
そういうことで 永遠な地獄が嫌だから悪いことを抑えるのであって
悪いことをするのは本当に悪いかということは考えません
行うべきリストと行うべからずリストがあれば十分です
だからその場合はリストさえ渡せちゃえばいいんです
永遠な地獄あるんだそうと言っている世界では
人にあなたはこのリストを守りなさいとリストくれればいいんですよ
実際 リストくれてるんです
これこれ守りなさいと
だからそれ自体もバカバカらしくて
人間の知恵っていうのは
人間の理性っていうのはバカにしているんですよ
だから あなたはいろいろごちゃごちゃ疑問にする必要はないんだと
このリストを守りなさいと
だから 道徳そのものに意味があるかないかということは考えなくてもいいんですよ
良い生き方をしても 正しい生き方をしているのだという充実感を得られない
それは最後の審判で決めるから
例えば もう神様みたいな永遠の地獄を怯えて良いことをしているんですけど
私は本当に良いことをしているんだ
いい人間だというね その充実感がないんですよ
それ禁止されています
皆様 私より聖書なんかはもう大変通だと思いますけど
禁止しているんですよ
最後の審判まで待ちなさいと
人を裁くなかれと これは私の権利やと
はい 自分のマニュアルから他のものをね
他を えーと 何でしたっけ？判断する
はた迷惑行為が絶えないんですね
これでリストを持って人を判断するんですよ
はた迷惑なんですね ローマ法王も言ったあの言葉なんかはね
前の法王にえらい批判がありまして
今の人にもものすごい批判があるんですよ
本当に聖者なのかと で
自分の固定概念で狭い範囲で物事を考えて
もう人を非難する それで向こうが攻撃しちゃうと
もう偉そうな格好つけて謝ったりもする
なんで自分の宗教はそんなに完全であったら謝る必要になるんでしょうかね
だってイスラエルに対してすごい堂々謝ったでしょうに
とにかくこのはた迷惑
まあ今 世界でね 日本でも電車に乗ったら不審物あったらもう言いなさいって言ったら
私は電車に乗ってるみんな不審物だって言いたいんですけどね
誰も信じられませんと
だって人間っていうのは何するかわからないんだからね
でも自分が忙しいんだから
言う暇がないんです まあだから
それでこのテロ行為が日本にもあるんだそうとかね
それは別にあるわけじゃなくても
もう勝手に日本人を脅してるだけですけど
まあそういうことは世の中にはいっぱいあるんでしょうね
宗教の名をとって もう他人に迷惑をかける
人殺す 殺して それが良いことだとまた言いやったりする
だってそういうことは自分のリストにないんだから
本当にコーランなんか面白い
何でもかんでもリスト化しているんですよ
結婚どうするのか 離婚どうするのかとかね
離婚するときは女にどれぐらいお金払っちゃえばいいかとかね
寄付する場合は何パーセントですかで一年とかね
そんなもうもう昔も砂漠で人殺しばっかしやってた時代で作った言葉だから
今現代に合わないことにいっぱいあるんですよ
泥棒したら手を切っちゃいなさいとかね
もう不倫したら石を投げて殺せとかね
今現代時代には合いませんよ
でもとにかくそういう
あの なんとかというこの法律をね
もうそれが法律にしたくてしたくて
結局迷惑ですよ だから永遠の地獄に酔って脅されると
そういうリストを持ってきて
リストに合わせて物事を見るということになるんです
道徳かないかっていうことを全然気にしないんですよ
私から見れば欠陥だらけなんですけど
はい 次に行きます 社会的道徳と地獄に支える道徳
道徳も 2つあるんですね
社会的道徳と地獄に 地獄が支えている道徳と
はい 社会の平和繁栄を期待し
また不正を制御するための社会的な道徳と法律があります
それを皆様は知っているような
常識な文化 人間の文明
人間の世界なんですね
我々の道徳は必要ですよ
何のためかというと もう社会の平和で繁栄のために人間が道徳を守らなくちゃいけないんでしょうね
それからまた不正を制御するために
そんなこと言ったっても
ちょこちょこと人間というのは不正的なことをやっちゃいますから
そこは戒めなくちゃいけないんですよ
こんなことやったらあかんぞ
やったら罰が罰はありますよと
そういうのはまあ 法律ですからね
そういうものは必ず必要なんです
こんなのは常識でわかりますね
必要ということは はい
次 それは人間が作るもので
だから社会的道徳というのは人間が作るものですよ
必要に応じて訂正 改良
改悪はできます だから我々作っている道徳なんですよ
我々は社会の繁栄 平和のために道徳を作ったんですよ
そこで道徳は足らないんだと
こんなもんでは平和にならないんだぞと言ったら
道徳を増やさなくちゃいけない
あるいはこんなのを守ったらもう大変意味がないんだと言うと
もう腐りかけている あるいはもう機能しない道徳を削除しなくちゃいけない
だから昔良いと思ったものは今はあまり良くないとあるでしょうし
昔悪いと思ったものは今はどうったことはないという道徳っていうのはいくらでもありますよ
だからもう訂正できますよ
人間作った道徳なら改良もできますし
改悪もできます で なんで改悪書いたのかというと
結構やってますからね
よく覚えてほしいものは
道徳っていうのは 我々は社会の平和繁栄のために
不正をなくすために作るものだから
まあ日々改良しながら改良しながら行っても決して悪くないんですよ
改良すればするほど 社会はより平和的な社会になって
より安定して繁栄するんです
はい 次 地獄に支える道徳は
人間の信仰 怯えによって成り立ちます
成立します それで地獄があるんだそう
地獄あるんだそうと言っちゃうと
みんな信仰か信じるか怯えるか
単なる信仰か怯えによって支えていますよ
ちょっとかっこ悪いんですよ
で 社会道徳はよく理性に基づいて
具体的な結果に基づいて支えているんです
だから理屈はないんですね
地獄に怯えて道徳を守る場合は
信仰か脅しですね 怯えですね
はい